and a woman leads Salah and he got next
money behind you and when the sister
goes and sajdah uh or Roku next man is
going to be you know oh you know maybe
loses will do
this winter bone sisters helped to feed
those who are in poor conditions and who
don't even have a clothing to keep
theirself warm your small donation might
mean nothing to you but it can change
their life and help them survive the
winter this year
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah so here
is a mosque or should I say a temple of
a group of individuals who have started
something new which is a better you know
it is actually a bitter not unqualified
people saying this is better or this
person innovator this actual Bida okay
how is it brothers and sisters
subhanallah
um as you can see that it is a temple
and in this Temple I'm going to hold a
temple here and you've got people of you
know all genders whatever you are
whoever you are what color you are open
to everybody Allah Habibi inshallah no
problem yeah and you've got a woman
leading the Salah now she's going to be
leading the Salah we're going to watch
it and there's a very specific place
where she's making and you can say Surah
Fati is some sort of adoi as well you
know um you know and we know the Hadith
that you know Allah responds so let's
watch it because I really want to say
I'm into one of the verses She resides
in the Quran um I'm not going to come to
is this actually even accepted and a
very profound profound saying from um in
Surah Russia about such people and their
likes don't miss this let's watch this
inshallah brothers and sisters inshallah
[Music]
show us the straight path uh uh I mean
I'm gonna say I'm in trouble with the
straight path because inshallah
those who have bestowed your grace
you know why because the verse that she
says that guide us to the straight path
the path of those who view your favorite
not of those who have earned your anger
I'm going to say Amin and if that Dua
has been accepted they would most likely
go and shut down the whole place because
that if you want to be on the Sarat you
don't go against what Islam has told you
to do we know for an action to be
accepted you need two things number one
the actions and intentions we can say
arguments like let's assume the best in
all of them their intentions are in the
right place they are doing this
genuinely for the sake of Allah no
problem but the actions have to follow
according to the Sunnah if it doesn't
follow according to the Sunnah it is
rejected from you so to think that
you're gonna make it all inclusive and
everybody can whoever they want they can
come and a woman leads Salah and you go
next Monday behind you and when the
sister goes in or Roku next man is going
to be you know oh you know maybe loses
will do yeah or maybe you need to do
Russell so the point is that's why the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him said
the best place to pray for a man is the
front and the worst is at the back of
the role and for a woman the best place
to pray for her is at the back and the
best in the front in the woman section
compared why because the fact that
they're close to each other it opens the
doors to fit now brothers and sisters
that is one of the reasons to pan Allah
that's why you don't have a woman
leading Salah with many reasons so once
again
inshallah gets answered that they made
and they shut down the whole place
because the mustachim is not what you're
doing so um when he saw a Christian man
a person of the book walking closely and
he looked at them and he said this in
Surah Russia
Bismillah he says he said
[Music]
what's the what is the verse say yeah
and he carries on
what does it say working hard and
exhausted so let's read the whole Ayah
Allah says as they read you the report
of the overwhelming event faces that day
will be humbled working hard on the
resources so he's talking about these
people who are coming they've been
working exhausted yeah they will enter
two burn in an intensely hot fire they
will be given to drink nothing but
boiling water um started crying you know
why he said look at this question he
doesn't get married he worships day and
night and all for something that is
going to lead him to the fire all that
effort that you are doing so these
sisters these brothers who are doing
this inshallah yeah I don't know if we
can uh let's go with a good assumption
all that effort that you're doing all
the Salah that you're doing whatever
you're doing in that place it is zero
not accepted now you're gonna come and
say Oh Brother Ali Only God can judge me
please shut up your respect please shut
up yes without Jerusalem I've had enough
of these people you can't drive this
heart you know if that girl comes oh it
says
there must be maybe his heart is good
you reward your Deeds are zero nullified
because you do not bring the conditions
that is needed for the action to be
accepted on the day of judgment you will
not see a single reward not that you
will also be punished for innovating in
the religion that's all I wanted to say
may Allah guide us and not make us so
insane cure in our religion that we have
to go to new norms and new things to
make Islam look you know all funny and
hunky-dory nobody will respect you
assalamu alaikum